hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my Series in which I
remake my first game in C plus plus and
I say that every time last episode which
was at the start of this week just
pumping these out we fixed our blurry
pixel problem and I made that video as a
whole to kind of show how I would
approach debugging Graphics related
issues so definitely check that out but
now now that we have our sharp pixels as
you can see very cool very sharp pixels
and in fact you can see that they're all
they're each three by three because if
you pay careful attention here you can
see how my little blurry uh drawing tool
thing you can see how the colors are a
bit different so you can actually count
the one two three pixels that each of
our kind of pixels are because our scale
is three so that's all perfect that's
all set up now what we're ready to do
hopefully is to look at the Java version
uh and actually start implementing this
kind of renderer it's kind of pixel
renderer that will actually render all
of these guys which also should be like
three by three pixels
which actually now that I'm zooming in
here it kind of looks like they're 4x4
isn't that strange
oh well yeah they seem to be four but
anyway we can now start actually
implementing this kind of renderer and
that's what we're going to do today so
as I kind of mentioned at the beginning
of the series I want to kind of
replicate this pretty much one for one
like as closely as possible to the
original version I will probably improve
some technical details because of course
this was like my first game and I will
probably also like make it resizable and
all of that stuff but I'm going to try
and essentially Port the game into C
plus plus so if we look at the
screen.java file by the way the
repositories will be in the description
below I haven't actually made any
commits for this actual game yet that
we're working on because there's
basically just random pixels at this
point in time I probably will maybe
after this episode but Genesis like the
original Genesis game that is on GitHub
and I'll have a link in the description
below so you can actually browse the
Java code and even play the game if you
want but basically if we have a scroll
through this class this is what we're
interested in implementing
um I should probably go over the
architecture a little bit basically
game.java the game class this is kind of
like the main the main class I guess of
this entire game and what happens is
inside the render function well there's
two kind of main functions here there's
an update function which will you know
update things and and level.update is
really like the the main meat of where
the game actually gets updated uh and
then we have uh inside the render
function we have level dot render and
you can see that takes in a screen
object over here which is an instance of
that screen class we looked at and the
reason it does that is because the level
itself will go through like the area on
the screen that we can actually see
right so the visible kind of boundary
because level could be you know massive
but obviously we're just kind of looking
into a window of that level and that's
what all these guys are determining that
kind of clipping area that we can
actually see here that we need to render
and then we'll go through that area that
we can see and get every tile by its
index so that we know what type of tile
it is so that'll be like one of these
squares and then we'll call tile.render
passing in the screen and so when we do
that we pass in the screen class you can
see there's nothing in here because
they're actually all kind of subclasses
now I don't think I'm going to set it up
this way this is like a very
object-oriented approach and I
definitely wouldn't do it this way just
because it's a complete not because
there's like anything
I think too bad with performance here I
mean yeah having like you know an
overridden function for every single
tile that you want to render is isn't
unnecessary like extra interaction to go
through to find the right you know
function via the V table and all of that
but
the I would say the real hassle is
having to create a separate class for
every tile type like that's just very
unnecessary you could set this all up to
essentially be tile and then just set
some parameters so for example a stone
tile uh you know what does it do for
rendering this which is pretty much what
every single tile does maybe there are
some exceptions but most of them do this
and then for solid it returns true so
why not put this into the base class and
then just make like some kind of uh
bullying in the actual tile class that's
whether or not it's solid and then that
way you can ask the tile is it solid for
that instance it would be true you know
what I mean like instead of actually
creating a new class for it that just
implements some data you can just store
the data in the actual class like in
that instance of the class
um and of course we don't even need to
use class instances if we really kind of
think about it but
whatever
um and you can see they also we do
actually set some data here thankfully
we set the Sprite so just like we set
the Sprite to be something
specific right
um we could also you know just be like
yeah by the way this is solid and then
we wouldn't need that whole like solid
false and then you know overwritten to
return true which is a bit weird but
whatever
um okay so if we go into like Stone
class for example you can see it does
screen around a tile it like will
basically multiply that X because that's
a tile coordinate by 16 to get up to
like pixel space so we know which pixels
to kind of start from that's like the
coordinate X pixel y pixel we'll
subtract the offset from it and what the
offset is is kind of like where the
player is where we should render it from
because the way it's rendered is the
player is supposed to be in the middle
so therefore there's going to be some
offset that's essentially like the
camera I guess and that's what happens
here and then we'll go through the
actual size of the Sprite Which is 16 so
this stuff is 16 by 16 pixels we'll go
through that and then we'll potentially
clip it over here
but otherwise we'll translate uh because
you can see this goes from 0 to 15 right
this folder will go from 0 to 15 to
cover all the pixels of the Sprite
however we need to put them somewhere
into the screen buffer and that's
obviously going to be at an offset
depending on where the actual tile
appears on the screen so that's what
this int YT is that's kind of offsetting
the actual kind of pixel inside the
Sprite by the position of the tile so
that we get it in that kind of you know
context of being on screen
um because we need to kind of I guess
transform it onto the right position on
the screen uh if it's like less than
zero like set it to zero so just doing
like some clipping here essentially
I don't really know if we need this it's
just because this was a bit weird right
I mentioned this I think in either the
code review or maybe yeah some video I
think probably the code review
um where this was basically like instead
of being zero for some reason I made it
kind of be one tiled back I guess
because this will be negative 16 uh but
then because that will obviously crash
because it can't read negative 16 from
here we have to then
um I guess clip it to zero
because this could end up being negative
I guess and that would be an array index
out of bounds exception I don't know
it's a bit weird you can also see that
if the tile isn't a torch tile we
actually change the brightness of the
color depending on the on the brightness
of the torch so that's also important
that's kind of our lighting that needs
to happen we need to change the
brightness
um but yeah that's overall like the
rendering so you can see what we're
doing we're basically just copying
pixels from the actual Sprite onto like
this screen that's what's Happening Here
we read the Sprite pixels and we copy
them into the relevant offset into the
kind of screen buffer and that's how
that works so inside LC Plus Code we
know that we have uh we have image data
which is essentially that buffer right
and we have an image which we then kind
of set over here so image set data is
kind of the same thing
as what happens in the game class
um over here
so this copying the pixels from the
screen pixels into our pixels which is
actually like the data buffer of the
image you can see that there's it's very
kind of analogous to like the actual C
plus code we also have an image and we
have that data buffer that's the same
thing as this image and this image data
and then this kind of active again I'd
mentioned this before but I don't know
if I don't know why exactly this is
actually copying it considering we could
have just given it a reference I guess
of that but that's basically what's
happening here this is essentially image
set data and then over here g dot draw
image that's basically where we draw it
here with I'm GUI like we're just
drawing it using Java's Graphics here
and I'm GUI here so that's pretty cool
it's very very similar so now all we
really have to do is actually render
something into these pixels but I think
what we don't have to do here which we
did in the Java version is screen
actually creates like its own pixels
array well it has a tiles array pixels
equals new in with times height so we
actually have two buffers in the Java
version we have like one that we get
from the image which is this and then
one that we actually allocate ourselves
but in our version we don't we don't
need that we just have this guy which is
the actual image and then image data
which is what gets kind of uploaded to
the GPU to actually be rendered all
right so we're pretty much ready to I
guess start implementing this screen
class and then maybe maybe we should
also try reading in some kind of image
so that we can render like a Sprite on
the screen that'll be pretty exciting
now if you're new to computer science
and you want to learn some math as well
I highly recommend you check out the
sponsor of this video brilliant What
brilliant is is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of courses on
various stem topics they have some
really really good introductory computer
science stuff that will really help you
kind of think as a programmer and also
my personal favorite is their mouth
stuff because their math stuff goes very
deep very Advanced and it's presented in
such a beautiful Visual and interactive
way like you have these widgets you can
play with they quiz you constantly to
make sure that you're actually learning
the content it's just such a beautiful
engaging way to learn that I find is fun
manageable because each kind of
individual class is bite-sized so you
can kind of get through it rather
quickly even if you don't have much time
and also really effective because the
way they teach you know visually and
interactively just works so well now
brilliant have actually expanded their
trial up to 30 days now so if you go to
brilliant.org the channel you can try
them for free for 30 days just browse
through their courses and see how you go
there's no reason not to try it out and
then if you really enjoy it brilliant
have been nice enough to offer the first
200 of my subscribers 20 off an annual
membership huge thank you as always to
brilliant for being a fantastic sponsor
on my channel alright so my strategy is
going to be um yeah I'm actually kind of
now that I'm thinking about this there's
probably almost no no point in actually
creating this screen class if we can't
we do have a clear function which clears
everything to Black that's exciting but
other than that like we need Sprites to
draw don't we so let's take a look at
the Sprite class quickly we have a
Sprite class which has a bunch of static
instances of like itself right and then
we have these kind of cryptic looking
numbers here but really what they are
are an x and y coordinate within a
Sprite sheet and a size I presume right
so X and Y you can see it gets
multiplied by 16 here as well so that we
um kind of treat this as a coordinate
rather than a pixel offset
um and then create will basically copy
okay so each Sprite contains its own
pixels buffer
okay so this is also a bit unnecessary
right because what this is is it so
every Sprite will contain its own pixel
buffer which is 16 by 16 pixels and then
the way we kind of create it is we copy
it from Sprite sheet.pixels Which
presumably Sprite sheet yeah is just
basically going to load like the image
that is the Sprite sheet which contains
all of the Sprites
um and that'll be the entire priority
but then also we copy it so that each
Sprite has its own individual array
again completely unnecessary because
anytime we want to render the Sprite we
could just use these existing pixels
like there's no reason for us to kind of
create I guess this many this many wow
there's a lot of Sprites this many
separate buffers
just to render each Sprite if they're
all contained kind of globally you know
inside this Sprite sheet and if we
actually look at the Sprite sheet
which is over here I'll kind of zoom in
here you can see that
um this is kind of what the Sprites look
like they're all packaged into a single
Sprite sheet now this is actually very
good this is going to be really really
useful to us because when later in the
series we move this to actually be
rendered you know Hardware accelerated
like on the GPU using Vulcan this is
very helpful because we can just have
one texture instead of trying to create
you know like I don't know 20 different
textures one for each Sprite and then
having to you know either bind them into
different texture slots or even draw
this price in different draw calls like
instead of doing all of that we can just
have them all in one texture uh and then
that's it we just set that texture onto
the GPU we upload the data and then we
can kind of reference like a sub image
from it which basically just means that
when it's time for us to sample a
particular Sprite we obviously just set
the texture coordinates to be like you
know this range and of course we'll get
into that when we actually do the the
Vulcanizing the GPU part okay so I think
actually I'm going to kind of go
backward it's here instead of
implementing the screen class let's
actually try and load a Sprite and then
we'll do the screen class at least
enough I think today we should be able
to have time to actually render
something and see it so let's kind of
try and work quickly here now the cool
thing is we do have an image class uh
inside of Walnut and the image class
um obviously will load stuff it will
load a texture or an image from a path
using stbi sdb image and then what it
will do is it will set it onto the GPU
now we don't want that in this case we
don't we don't actually want this to be
set onto the GPU so I'm wondering if
maybe it will be it would make sense for
us to modify Walnut and allow Walnut for
us to kind of do local storage only in a
way so what that means is don't upload
it to the GPU just keep the data on the
CPU that's all I want
um should we do that because the
alternative is basically we don't do
that and instead what we do is we just
use SCB image ourselves inside Genesis
inside the game to just load you know
the data and that's it so I don't know
let me know if you guys want to see me
modify Walnut like in this series at all
maybe I shouldn't do that but it would
be a useful function to have it's just
obviously image is very heavily kind of
tight with the GPU as well so it might
be might be a little bit of of work
um now SCB image I think it's really the
other problem though is I don't know if
Genesis actually includes the include
path for this it probably doesn't so if
we look at the yeah I think we'll just
do it manually to be completely honest
um like I said we'll use stb image
ourselves it's kind of what you get to
see here me making all these decisions
live because I haven't planned any of
this this is all kind of happening
naturally
so inside
would it be I guess in the pre-make for
Genesis
um if we kind of go back here and we
open up the pre-mag for Walnut this is
probably going to include
um or maybe it's independencies so it
will not external okay let's kind of
look at this what's well not external so
include directory
Does it include
it has to include the directory for stb
image right because otherwise like where
is SCB image located oh maybe it's just
in
let's just say
now it's in Venda stb image so this has
to be sdb image has to be an include
directory okay well if we look at
walnuts property Pages we can actually
see that sdb image is included here
um but I'm not sure what pre-make is
actually doing that
it's got to be like the Walnut pre-make
right
isn't this what I looked at before
or did I look at Walnut app no
oh I was in Walnut I like to I looked at
this but I didn't look at the actual
Walnut one okay here it here it is so
you can see vendor stb image is being
included here so what we can do is we
can just copy this basically and then if
we go into
um and there's there might be better
ways to set this up like possibly
by having a separate dependencies.lure
file or something like that just to kind
of keep them all in one place but if we
go into the pre-make
um and we actually take a look at
Genesis so if we go into like the
Genesis pre-make which is over here
um then just like we include all of this
stuff we can also include it'll be
walnuts I think Venta stb image and
because the implementation is already
defined here so you can see when we
included here we Define stb image
implementation that means that this
image.cpp file which compiles into like
image.obj which is like the actual
compiled code that will contain this so
Walnut builds into a static Library
which contains stb images implementation
which means we of course don't need to
implement it here on inside Genesis and
if we do it'll probably tell us that we
have multiple defined symbols so what we
can do here I guess is we can add a new
um now is this just like what's the file
structure here yeah okay so inside
source I'll add a new item here
we might want to move this out a bit but
I'll just call it Sprite sheet so I'll
copy the Java version for now
um that's the kind of fun stuff that's
the fun thing about making a game we can
just
actually make the game and not worry
about like oh how do we make this like
all generalized and stuff I guess I'll
do namespace genesis which I haven't
haven't been doing yet
but that would be nice
um
and so we'll just say uh class I was
almost going to type public class Sprite
like in Java uh we'll take in uh
cons sad file system path
will include file system
is that
oh what am I doing
file system path path
um I guess we can have a Destructor
we'll see if we make that do anything
though let's Implement these guys just
using visual assist
uh
and I guess we can like keep track of
what the path is that might be useful
for like debugging I don't think we'll
realistically need that
um but
like for the actual game but we can
still kind of keep track of that so I'll
just set it over here
um okay and then we'll just load it
using stb image so we should have that
include directory set up hopefully kind
of doesn't look like it is okay it's not
oh I didn't regenerate the things so if
we go back to Genesis
um remake here into the root directory
rerun setup that will hopefully uh add
that in and if we control F7 the file
now should work beautiful
um okay and now we need to load it so
what does the Java version do it just
loads the image and it keeps it just
keeps the pixels here and there's also a
fixed size for some reason I don't think
there needs to be a fixed size but sure
now if we open up this Sprite thing the
problem is I can't
I don't know if eclipse
how do I just open the show in no
open with
open how do I just view the file
location for this
is complete our look there's a URL
let me just grab that directory
um okay so surprised.png I guess we'll
copy all the assets at this point in
time
um
and we'll copy them into over here into
our kind of
um Genesis remake over here this is the
root directory but inside the project
I'll make a folder called res resources
which will contain everything so
everything should be relative to this
because this should be our working
directory at this point in time
um so it's just red slash sprites.png
will be the the path uh and then we'll
just kind of let's go back to like maybe
Genesis app and we'll try and just kind
of already start writing the code that
loads it so if we include Sprite sheet
let's do like I'm sure we can do a
shared pointer Genesis Sprite sheet I'll
probably make this file inside the
Genesis namespace in the future actually
we should probably move this out
um but I'll just call this Sprite sheet
and then
um let's do Supply cheat equals seam
actually has price cheat and we'll do
res slash sprites.png so there's our
Sprite sheet um now we have to obviously
load it so if we go back to Walnut image
to see how we would use sdb image to
load it this will just be quicker
um so it's not going to be an HDR it's
just going to be a normal kind of um RGB
a I guess or even an RGB texture so this
is what it is so
um let's just copy this line
we'll go back to our supply chain
uh we'll kind of keep a buffer of pixels
here
which I don't know I guess
we can just do un8t what we want okay so
the thing is
no I guess we'll just make the 32t well
we can do with SCB image by the way is
we can force it to have four channels so
even if the image itself is only RGB uh
it's actually going to pad it out so
that it is
um kind of four channels one by per
channel so we have four bytes per pixel
the reason why that's useful is because
that means each pixel is this data type
you can't really have a 24 bit data type
um I mean you can if you really wanted
to but we don't kind of have one as
default so uh because of that it's just
better to kind of Pat it out I guess
it'll just be easy to deal with we could
just also store them all as just this
and then just know that it'll be like
for example three bytes between pixels
if it's RGB but I think this will
probably be easier
um so I'll just call this pixels
now the thing is
yeah I mean I'm gonna just allocate this
on the Heap I guess uh but you probably
could also do it on the stack will it
fit probably because it's just well it's
not that big although two it is about
256 by four it's probably big
so maybe you wouldn't want to do that um
because you only have about a megabyte
of Stack space and I probably don't want
it to be taken up by this so we can just
do pixels if we're sure we know the size
of it which I'm going to say we don't
we'll allocate it later ourselves and
we'll make sure we delete it here now I
did see a comment so I'm saying you can
use a vector for this I'm aware you can
use a vector for this what you can do is
you can kind of just make a vector like
that and then you can just obviously do
when you know the size you can just do
resize and then it will
um kind of resize the back to reallocate
the vector to be that certain size and
then you can use dot data to get like
the raw pointer for it I honestly just
don't always like doing that and the
only benefit of doing that by the way
really is um I guess you know the size
of it because you can ask it what the
size is pixels.size uh that's the that's
a that's a good benefit but then also
you don't have to delete it because when
you know this vector's allocated on the
stack and like the data's on the Heap
but it will delete the data on the Heap
industry in the destructor of the actual
Vector if that makes sense
I don't know know I there's no real
difference I don't mind doing it the
wrong way because like you know as long
as you just remember to delete it it's
probably fine
um but if you want to do it the vector
way then sure do it the right way so um
pixels will kind of just be this now
oh yeah I should mention that so you
should probably use stbi free or what is
it stb3 stb image free I think right
all right we can look at well not to see
what it does
so what does release do
well actually what does it even do sdb
image free yeah isn't that what I wrote
yeah
that does look like what I write so we
can do that
I don't know why that's not uh defined
oh it's sdbi image free okay
um okay so the path we put in here now
yeah the annoying thing is it once the C
strings over we actually have to do is
file path string is paths.string which
will convert it from wide characters to
normal characters and then we have to do
this which is a little bit annoying now
with height I guess we can store here
now what is this this is an ant so we
can just store it as an ant
because otherwise it might be upset at
us I'll initialize these to zero always
a good idea to initialize these things
passes need to be initialized because
it's a class so it'll automatically be
initialized
um so width height now channels um it
probably doesn't matter if we say what
our desired channels are so if we pass
in zero here it will tell us what the
channels are so just for curiosity we
can actually leave this in here
um now what's this upset with yeah so
what is it stbuc
what is our 10.
stvi you see
so it has to be I unsigned Char is what
that is so that's actually a one byte
format but we can cast it to something
else if we want to
um
and then it will just treat it as the
kind of 32-bit one uh integers that we
want to trade it as now why are you
upset
oh I'm casting it to this that's not
what I meant it's that I'm trying to
cast it to this okay
um yeah so I'm interested to kind of if
we just do a debug break here which is
kind of Windows only but it's temporary
um I'm just going to use this to just
see what the channels are it'll probably
be three and if we pass in zero here
um then it will not assume anything if
we tell it something then it will in
fact set it to like be four uh four
bytes per pixel or four channels
um and I guess because they're going to
be not like floating Point there'll be
one byte per Channel but if we just I
guess if we just run that because
Genesis app loads that right so let's
try and run that
all right so let's see uh channels yeah
three right
um and so that's fine but we're gonna
put in four here so we'll just actually
Pat it out to be
um RGB a I guess uh and in that case we
probably don't need channels can we just
pass in null is that valid or is it
going to try and write to that no matter
what load from file I don't know if I
want to keep digging through this to be
completely honest yeah so you can
actually see this is the number of
channels that it writes out it seems to
only write it out if it's not null
that's what this if check does so I
guess if you if you really don't care
you can actually pass in null and you'll
be right so I'll do that to keep it a
bit cleaner okay cool there's our pixels
now if that didn't work we can probably
like report an error or something so if
pixels
didn't work
um you know
could not load image
path okay
awkward not loads prior chairs so
that'll just be useful to us in case it
doesn't work and then I'm assuming this
will be fine because pixels will be null
so this is just checking if it's null
and if it's null we'll print out an
error message
um but I'm assuming this should be okay
with null because it's just calling free
so that'll be fine you can free null and
it won't do anything
um okay great so we have that uh now
just like we had over here actually in
the Java version we may have just had
yeah this was just public and it was in
fact static as well
um so we can make this public but we can
also just you know get pixels make a
little function called get pixels and
then have that return pixels
and then I guess we can have get with
and get hide
so we can have some of these Getters
um and set us here which to be honest I
usually like it's not that I avoid them
if you have both Getters and Setters you
should just make the variable public but
if you only if you kind of have it as a
read-only thing which is what we're
doing then
um it's probably about it's just uh
write it like this okay beautiful so we
have a supply chain we have the pixels
um we should now be able to render
something
um now I think we'll end up implementing
like the screen class properly next
episode just because this is already
dragging on but uh I think what I will
do is I'll try and load like a specific
Sprite I guess and we could even make
like a little system here
so that we could index the Sprites
properly and just ask for a specific
Sprite type
which could be could be useful I guess
but um what we'll do is we'll we'll try
and like render a Sprite I guess over
here
by just copying it essentially from the
Sprite sheets so let's find a Sprite
that we want to render
um if we're going to Res Sprites
okay so I guess we'll run to the player
so this is the player we'll render this
guy over here so that's going to be from
the I guess bottom of the image is where
we'll index it from zero one two three
four five six seven eight so eight on
the Y and two on the X
so 2 8 is what we want to render so how
do we do that well we can get the pixels
let's just get a pointer to
Sprite sheet pixels
and then let's think about this so to in
order for us to uh offset ourselves into
the right kind of coordinate we need to
okay well let's write out the coordinate
first I'll try and make this as clear as
possible so X is true Y is eight that's
our coordinate so Step One is let's
convert this into pixels what is the
pixel offset both in X and Y so that's
going to be
um and XP I'll say 2 times the size of
each Sprite Which is 16.
so let's make a Sprite size variable
let's do 2 times 16 on sorry not 2 times
16 x times 6 times 16 right so we're
using the coordinate here and then y
times Sprite size so that gets us into
um what am I doing YP equals that
writing two variables per line here very
cool
um so we've got the we've got the pixel
like coordinate now so now we have to
use that as an index into here but it
also gets complicated a little bit here
because when we actually read this and I
want to see how I did it here
yeah so you can see what happens is when
we Loop through this in order to copy it
we actually have to so we we read just X
and Y which is from 0 to 15 that makes
sense but then in here we do X plus we
kind of have to go through each
coordinate
um because what you have to realize is
that like when you're within a Sprite
sheet and you have a coordinate here
it's not just like you go from this
coordinate because if you go from this
coordinate you'll just go straight so
what you still need to do is you need to
make sure when you get to the edge you
start going on to the second kind of
scan line if that makes sense because
it's going to be kind of an elderly from
bottom to top but you can you kind of
have to stop here even though the
texture obviously doesn't stop here so
it's not just about getting to the right
place you know vertically it's also
about kind of wrapping around but if you
do it this way that will candle it for
you because you'll have the kind of
um this dot X will be the Sprite in this
case that will be the coordinate within
the Sprite tree the offset the starting
offset within the Sprite sheets are over
here and then because you're doing X and
Y plot because these are all kind of
individual coordinates when you get to
the end here which is going to be 15 on
X you'll go to the next y level and
you'll go back to zero which means you
go back to the start so that's actually
going to work fine so if we'll if we
copy that what we'll do is we'll write
essentially this Loop so from actually I
can just copy it
flat out just copy it
so size is going to be our Sprite size
this can remain the same I'll say XC for
this which stands for x coordinate just
so that we're in conflict with X and Y
here and then what we'll do is
um basically to access the Sprite that
we're looking for at a particular
coordinate this is us accessing the
actual like color of that pixel
so I'll just say color
that's going to be just move this a bit
more
that's going to be the same thing as it
was here so X plus this dot X so in this
case X will be one of these guys so it's
going to be X Plus and then this dot X
is going to be XP so that's where within
the Sprites here we want to be at and X
is actually the kind of within the
Sprite if that makes sense I know this
might be a little bit confusing I'll
maybe try and draw this but XP is our
position within the Sprite sheet so this
is going to be like say this dot here
and remember XP is constant across this
entire these entire for Loops what
changes in these for Loops are X and Y
which is the kind of sprite coordinate
so from 0 to 16 or 0 to 15 inclusive
right so what we'll do I'll draw it in
blue here is we get that starting
coordinate of the Sprite and then we
start adding well the first iteration we
just add zero to it right so we just add
zero to it so we grab that pixel that's
the color and then we'll go forward
horizontally until we do that 16 times
well all the way up to 15 and then we
drop you know y plus plus happens we
drop Y is now one which means we go up
one row and X is back to zero so we go
here and I'll draw this in Orange this
is our second row now and then we go
through and do that so that's what this
is doing it's just offsetting the XP
which is our actual kind of starting
position of the Sprite by X which is the
value from 0 to 15 that's the pixel
within the Sprite I guess that we're
trying to copy lots of stuff going on
um okay and now of course we need to do
that for y as well so y p plus y
and we multiply this by the um width of
our Sprite sheet so a Sprite sheet
get width and the reason why is because
you can see this is a this is like a
one-dimensional array but which we're
trying to trade it with like
two-dimensional coordinates so the way
we do that is when we have our
y-coordinate we're multiplied by the
width so that we get to the row that
we're after so if this was the Sprite
sheet you can see that if I want to get
to like you know let's just say we have
all these rows here if I want to get to
this row over here to the starting point
of this row over here what do I do well
if it's single Dimension we know the
width of the row let's just say it's
like well it's 256 right so if I want to
get to this guy it's going to be this is
going to be the coordinate to 256 or the
index 256 because this is 0 to 255 right
and similarly this is going to be 256 to
511 which means this is 512. and so how
can I get there well I know that's row
two so two times 256 is what 512 right
so it just helps us kind of get to the
right row and then within the row we
just add this offset so you can see the
multiplication really happens here so
this is what gets multiplied with the
width not this this just gets added on
later
that's why it's important for us to have
these brackets here because we don't
want to do y times that we want to do YP
plus Y which is the complete kind of
coordinate uh of the pixel coordinate
times the width and then we add this on
so if this was like I don't know the x
coordinate was like five halfway through
the halfway through the row but a bit
into the row then of course it would
just move it like to here and that's it
so that's how that kind of offset Works
hopefully that made sense
um kind of rush through that okay so we
have the color we have the color we have
the value that we want to kind of copy
now we just need to decide where inside
this image buffer do we place it now um
what we could do is place it right into
the middle so let's try to do that
um
so nines uh well 960 by 540 we can't
really trust because it'll be resized so
let's just say the middle
um let's do it up here so metal uh X
will be image get worth divided by two
uh and then image get height divided by
two will be the middle y
so if we basically grab the
um x t x Target lots of like little
acronyms and variable names here what we
can do is we can say that it's going to
be middle X but we'll subtract half of
the Sprite size so what that's going to
do is obviously start it up
um you know if this is the very middle
of the actual display it's going to move
it back by the by half the Sprite size
so that we actually get it properly
rendering in the middle
um we'll do the same thing for y
um okay and now we have our starting
Target X and Y which by the way can
totally be done up here
uh no need to do that inside the for
Loop and then we'll actually put the
pixels into the image so that's going to
be inside image data we'll copy in at
XT
plus X because that's the actual that's
which pixel we're copying whereas XT is
just like the starting coordinate so
again we have that starting coordinate
and then the X which changes according
to the for Loop lets us kind of expand
it into this area right
um
and each iteration of the follow for
Loop copies one color copies one pixel
and then this will be times the uh image
get width
so we'll set that equal to color
and that's it that should be it so I'm
very excited let's hit F5 and hopefully
this will work
Okay so
so we got the wrong Sprite but it does
look like we did get a Sprite I wonder
why we got the wrong Sprite
would have been fun if you guys just saw
me completely mess up so we got the lion
so
uh maybe it's counting Counting from the
top zero one two three four five six
seven eight well yeah that would be the
lion so it's so it is going from the top
interesting
okay well let's try and set that to
seven
I wonder why it's going from the top
and there's our player
all right beautiful
um yeah that's pretty cool yeah why it's
going from the top is a bit of a mystery
to me
um I would have expected it to go from
the bottom especially because everything
else seems to I guess everything else
isn't matter though but it's possible
that it's just because when we load this
um maybe stbi loads images that way I
know there's like a flip
vertical vertical on load or whatever
stbi set flip vertically on load and if
we do that I think we'll get the lion
here
um and we'll get the line upside down in
fact which makes sense so we'll
obviously leave that off and then we'll
just count it from the top I guess so
there you go I learned something
um now one last thing we'll do today
is uh you can see that we have this pink
background which is a bit annoying right
um and clearly the pink is supposed to
be Alpha now why I didn't just make this
uh Sprite sheet which I keep losing why
I didn't make the spreadsheet just like
rgba
um and then make this Alpha is beyond me
I don't know why again probably because
I saw that notched it this way
um but that's totally fine as well if
you define a color any color to be your
transparent color or any two colors like
we have this kind of purple here which I
think is like
um probably like seven F zero zero seven
f
um and then this is ff00ff right
um if you define these colors to be
transparent it's very easy to kind of
implement that because all you do is you
say that hey if the color is that color
so this will be a 24 bit color obviously
but we only read that in so this is
probably going to be zero to be honest
so if the color is let's just try this
if the color is ff00ff then we can just
say continue because that's a
transparent color right or the
alternative would have been of course to
write it
like this if it doesn't equal that draw
it right but I find it's a bit cleaner
to just be like continue if it's that so
let's see if that works no okay so it
probably padded it out with FF then so
this would be
fff00ff so it's going to be a 32-bit
kind of value and there you go you can
see that we now have our character and
we have like a transparent background
right
um like we can see the pixels kind of
changing behind
our player and that's probably going to
look terrible with like YouTube
compression but
you get what you get
maybe I should do like live
presentations feel like a stadium with
people and just teach this kind of stuff
um and then you can see it live where
you won't see any video compression
that'll be exciting so yeah that's
basically the basics like that's
honestly like that's the basics we can
now read in individual Sprites you can
see that we avoided doing it the way
that we did in the Java version which
was by like every single Sprite you know
copying uh the pixels from the supply
chain into its own buffer for some
reason it doesn't need that it can just
reference the existing ones uh the
existing like single buffer which is the
whole Sprite sheet and just copy
whatever it needs um on demand now there
was this was a bit finicky like you can
see there's a lot of stuff going on here
so what we could do is definitely
provide an API for that
um if we wanted to again which I don't
know if we do want to
um but you could even write like a
function you know being like copy you
know a copy from Sprite sheet to this
buffer and it would kind of
automatically Implement that all you
have to do is give it a coordinate and
an offset within the original buffer so
that's also possible that's very
possible and then you could kind of
implement the for Loop inside that
function
lots of ways to kind of simplify this
and expand this
um and I guess I probably will commit
this I'll try and Commit This and I'll
have a link to it in the description
below but I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button
um yeah I'm really enjoying the series
so far to be honest it's bringing back
lots of memories and it's so fun to
revise this stuff kind of like me in the
future you know me now Having learned
like everything that I learned you know
looking looking at this stuff and
implementing this it's like you know
just looking at it from a whole
different perspective from a whole
different from a whole new light which
is really cool so I hope you guys are
enjoying this series as well if you have
any questions as always just leave them
in the comments below I'll try and kind
of address them in the next episode but
yeah I think next time we'll actually
Implement that screen class and we'll
maybe try and draw like a map of tiles
or something like that or at least we'll
progress into that into that direction
so thank you guys for watching don't
forget to check out brilliant Link in
description below and I will see you
guys next time goodbye